Kevin we were on the red carpet talking
to some friends that were going through
the line we were just joining them and
they were filmmakers and their film was
being honored and you know it was such a
high point in their lives to be on this
red carpet and honored and then they
just quietly told us that it's so
interesting because even though it was
such a high point in their life life
that they hadn't ever been that broke in
their entire life and here they were
being treasured and and things seemed so
great but there was this downside where
money wasn't coming in I know for you
you had talked about going to these
different festivals and you went to the
Napa Valley Film Festival and you had
this Calgon moment where it was just
this amazing room and you felt like a
prince but at the same time you felt
that maybe it was such it was a contrast
for you can you talk to them absolutely
I would say weeks prior to that my
personal finances not film festival
finances that I have no control over and
I'm just very thankful for and still am
I have five festivals starting in 2012
but personally the money vaporized and
but I was basically living from festival
to festival based on I hope they have
food at this one Wow
and then there was no I couldn't like
can I borrow money that's just not the
way yet but it happens it happens but
might I'm a beggar and subject of the
doc you know you don't have those
conversations so Napa Valley was a good
example of one of those situations were
like oh man I don't want then we get
this email from that bomb or I'm forward
and on it and they're just treating me
like I'm the greatest artists of the
21st century oh we can't wait for you to
be here and you're gonna be one of
weren't you here for the entire festival
I had two screenings there and I was
there for the entire five days and so I
arrived there totally penniless I can't
even I can't even use a credit card that
they need the card for the hotel but I
support exactly I don't have I mean but
what I'll do is I promise I won't lots
of TV I swear I won't read anything or
whatever so by going to the room and
it's almost like you know I'm one of the
it's for the United Nations and so that
contrast is it was very I've been
thinking along those lines for a long
time because this has been an ongoing
process and I've started to wonder it
felt like there's going to be into this
and it's grounding me and preparing me
for whatever the next thing is but you
need to take everything out of your
pockets and you need to take your ring
off and this is you so I'm not supposed
to have oh man I got like 20 G's in the
bank then I could just do what I want
you have nothing but who you are as an
artist and that's the only reason why
you're doing these festivals so it
really galvanized Who I Who am I really
as an artist it really doesn't have
anything to do with Beckford when I did
don't knock the rock I made four hundred
dollars in like ten minutes and
south-by-southwest I made 300 Sarasota
300 Tucson - and I was making money at
all the festivals but then all of a
sudden for all kinds of various reasons
people would give me standing ovations
and the screen is the qat
but they wouldn't buy one CD and all
shut completely down and I couldn't say
ladies in general we had a spiritual
epiphany but I need you to buy my CD now
it just would that's not a conversation
that could happen so I was just like I'm
here this is part of this path and it
just kind of totally vaporized and I
spent the rest of the several festivals
trying to figure out how to be in
between each one and I was able to
because if it was the kickstarter
official let's just say I was in between
New Jersey and Philadelphia in Palm
Springs or something and I couldn't get
back the Kickstarter would pay for the
hotel for those several days in between
because it made more sense to stay
because it was in route as opposed to
you know so there were times when
Kickstarter kicked in but it wasn't just
every single time Kevin I'm gonna go
throw darts at a pub can you give me a
couple of bucks I can buy some beer you
know no it was only specifically for you
know so the dichotomy of having
everything for you and being treated
like royalty - personally literally
sleeping at a bus stop one night or not
sleeping but sitting there
and then riding the bus like should I
could ride the bus all the way downtown
then back that one good me dinner an
hour late we'll start getting light then
I'll be cool you know so or a coffee
shop in Santa Monica this open 24 hours
you know so yeah I think if that's one
thing that the Great Recession has done
is it's made people realize that they're
not their net worth they're not they're
not and that's interesting that you say
that one thing that I like to do is
write affirmations on pieces of paper
and put them around the house of things
that I want in my life
what do you do to manifest things in
your life what what is your way of
bringing forth the success that you've
had with the festivals the result of
meeting Jay even though you didn't know
that Jay Duplass was a fan of yours how
do you how do you manifest all this well
I think I'm glad you asked the question
I think right now I'm learning to do
what I was doing early on and but I
became so experienced of something and I
had a hiatus that I came back that I
forgot that component now when you were
conscious of the component sometimes
that could that could negate it because
you're doing a formula so the key is to
get away from the formula and actually
become and manifest actually not like
Peter Pan or magic but actually
genuinely manifest the things that you
need and want you hopefully put them
better than a cup of people as well but
I'm learning how to do that again you
write down affirmations that's a good
suggestion I've heard that before maybe
I'll start doing it but most of it right
now is focused in on what I'm trying to
do at the end of these festival runs and
what's getting ready to happen for me in
2012 I have to decide exactly what that
is whether it leads I'm gonna be touring
what I'm gonna be writing new songs
where I'm going to be living so when we
say those things we're actually
manifesting them you know you make a
decision to go back to college you go
back to UPS or to write another album
those are manifestations and so more if
you say you know what man I don't even
know man because these people are so
rude
I probably won't even even care anymore
that's a manifestation so we have to be
careful when we randomly utter these
things and mix them in with what you're
trying to do because that's not a good
mix so as we get older spiritually if
there's such a thing as aging
spiritually it probably not but we have
to know we're more responsible and we're
more mature so when we say things that's
what it actually really is so thanks for
reminding me of it because I that's
what's going on with me right now
these next three six months are real
important for me as an artist because
I'm choosing to do this in this alone
you know this is not a part time I work
and then when I get a chance I don't
have your family you know any immediate
family now so it's like a decision I'm
making I want to actually do this for
the next several years you know whether
I go on a Greyhound bus and perform the
places I have no idea right now you're
asking me how I do it and you're also
telling me that it's time to do it now
so thank you when did that the shift in
your mind happen when you say you know
what it's not gonna be part-time I want
this this is my life this is it and you
and you told the universe and you told
yourself that do you remember where you
were when that happened was that good I
think it's pretty much right now right
now I mean I think that that's been
that's been really literally it's been
happening and I kind of maybe have said
it but when you say I kind of maybe have
said it then that means you kind of
maybe will do it which means you won't
do it oh but when you're confirming
things with other people on now other
people
that's what confirmation is when you get
your confirmation that means somebody
else that's another spiritual being
that's very interested in I say I am I
in my interpretation I've confirmed that
now so
that's what I'm that's what I'm doing it
that's what I'm doing pill courage is a
perfect launch point for that yeah yeah
thank you
Christmas Day
[Music]